i'm a big fan of the underdog and
because that's who i was my whole life
um i'm not big into like fancy degrees
and all of that those
which by the way if you have a fancy
degree great but it's not the thing that
i'm i really focus on
i focus on um the process uh the grit
alex rodriguez and jennifer lopez have
officially called it quits
splitting up one of the world's richest
power couples the pair who started
dating in 2017
and got engaged two years later wielded
huge pop culture and commercial
influence
jlo is one of america's wealthiest
self-made women with a net worth of more
than 150 million dollars for her music
film and endorsements and a-rod is one
of the top earning athletes ever
forbes estimates his fortune to be at
least 400 million dollars
today his business empire spread across
three main silos
real estate consumer products and health
and wellness
i've always had this entrepreneurial
spirit of me ever since i was a young
man i think i
came up looking at at my mother who uh
who was an entrepreneur herself
and my father who was really good with
numbers and we as a kid
in washington heights we owned a shoe
store and i saw
my father selling shoes all day long he
was great with numbers he never
needed a calculator and i think in many
ways i wanted to be like him
the ex-couple has joint investments in
jlo beauty luxury real estate and
venture-backed startups
two early tech companies they invested
in together went public earlier this
year
insurance company oscar health and
telehealth startup hims and hers
partners
but the bulk of their portfolios are
largely separate and focused in
different areas
a-rod isn't missing a beat prior to the
breakup rodriguez shocked the sports
world
announcing that he and jet.com founder
mark lore were in talks to purchase a
majority stake in the nba's minnesota
timberwolves
a deal that would value the team at 1.5
billion dollars
a-rod has plowed much of his energy and
money into real estate in southeastern
florida
so many athletes start the career
go from rags to riches back to rags
and i found that just terribly
concerning and disturbing
and i didn't want to be one of those
negative statistics where a player
went out and made a small fortune and
then fell into tough times
so i started with what i knew best is as
a child from a single mother
i knew apartments because we always
rented and we had to move
every six months so the first time i had
an opportunity
to make an investment i bought a duplex
down in south florida in miami
and a couple years later sold it for
double and then got a four plex
and then a 16 plex and finally about 60
units i grew that portfolio to about 14
000 apartment units in about 13 or 14
states
all over the southeast in secondary and
tertiary markets and
now obviously we've been around now for
over 20 years since
inception a-rod corp has amassed a stake
in more than 14
000 multi-family residential properties
and developed more than 15 million
square feet of real estate
while he's hung up his bat for good
a-rod remains as competitive as ever
you gotta have the vision you gotta have
enough capital
uh to feed the business and then you
have to have the right people
in place uh to help you execute uh
that vision um the other part i've
learned is you know stay in your circle
of competence
really focus on what you're passionate
about and what you understand really
well
and then you're really an average of the
five people you surround yourself with
and then have an economic alignment uh
when you win you all win and that comes
from
sports what i learned from george
steinbrenner with the yankees
is you have to have an environment where
you share the ball and i've always said
that i've always i'd rather have a small
piece of a watermelon melon
than a big piece of a lemon
you